bye
[Music]
put your feet
um
here's the cables
um
okay
check check check
check one two check check check on
channel two right
okay and you see what on channel one
isolated
and now
[Music]
put me down
break
is
[Music]
[Music]
i won't let you turn around and tell me
now i'm much too proud to walk away from
something when it's dead
when you are hurt there's certain things
[Music]
i won't let you turn around and tell me
now i'm much too proud all you do is
fill me up
this without baby
this time baby
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
babies
this
[Music]
uh
[Music]
who should take me home tonight
[Music]
tonight
the edge
[Music]
yes
[Music]
with you
as a reminder today's event has been set
up to adhere to social distancing
guidelines as outlined by health experts
in the state of michigan
thank you for being
my name here all right all right
it's hard to feel my rush
to rush the dangers
i'm gonna run right to the
with you where we can put
[Music]
[Music]
yes with you
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm on the edge
[Music]
oh
thank you
oh
i'm gonna have myself
[Music]
[Music]
at the speed of light i wanna make this
[Music]
if you wanna have a good time
i'm out oh control ready
[Music]
hey don't stop me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
if you wanna have a good time
at allah
[Music]
no matter how hard
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
do you believe
[Music]
do you believe
[Music]
what am i supposed to do
is
and maybe i'm too good for
do you believe in life after
i can feel something inside me say
i really don't think you're strong in
that love
[Music]
i really don't think you're strong
enough
[Music]
[Music]
i don't need you anymore
i don't need you anymore
i don't need you anymore
i really don't think you're stronger
i really don't make
[Music]
i really don't think you're strong
enough
do you believe
i can feel something inside me
i really don't think you're strong
[Music]
[Music]
chance this is your moment baby
[Music]
desperation
to depend on i'll be here
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is when you've lost your way in the
[Music]
wilderness
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the ceremony of your innocence
[Music]
the price of salvation is your
loneliness
and you can call me when you're anything
you're better
when you're ready
[Music]
we're stronger together
[Music]
is
come on baby
oh
um
[Music]
[Music]
but the times have changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
some people choose to
is
right between the eyes
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i love her
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
senator gary peters
well good afternoon everyone and uh
welcome
and certainly i am just so pleased to be
here to welcome
joe biden to michigan it is so great to
have him back
and we know joe loves coming to michigan
he's been here so many times and we know
he loves this state and he has fought
for us on so many occasions i
particularly remember during the
financial crisis when our
auto industry was in a very difficult
spot
and i just say thank god that joe biden
stood up for the auto industry and made
sure michigan continued to be the center
for the autos and i'm so happy to be
here with governor whitmer
as well and all the work that she has
been doing to keep folks here in
michigan safe
governor whitmer believes in science she
believes
in facts and because of that
our state is in a much better position
than would we would be otherwise
and then it's great to be here with my
colleague debbie stabenow
debbie shares uh our passion for health
care to make sure everybody has access
to quality care whether it's
community health centers reducing the
price of prescription drugs
or dealing with mental health challenges
debbie is my partner we're the one-two
punch when it comes to representing the
state of michigan in the united states
senate but we're here today to talk
about health care
and how important it is for us to focus
on the fact that everybody in this
country
should have access to quality affordable
healthcare particularly now
while we're in the midst of a pandemic
and what we have learned during this
pandemic
that we need leadership we need national
leadership to guide us through this
and joe biden has proved that he
can deliver that type of leadership in
fact when we were looking at the
affordable care act as we were passing
that
the beginning of the obama
administration it was joe biden
who helped lead and usher that through
and made it a reality so it became law
joe biden as a result of that has helped
thousands of people
all across the state of michigan and
millions all across our country
and it was an incredible fight i
remember that fight as we
were elected officials and folks
republicans were trying to demonize it
and attacking it and fought against us
every step of the way
i represented a really a pretty
republican district i had just got
elected and i was the first democrat
since 1893 to represent that district
and as we were dealing with the
affordable care act debate folk said
gary if you vote for this there's no way
you're going to get reelected this is a
real republican district and they're
coming at you
so what did i do i read the bill and as
i read it i said you know it's not
perfect but it really moves us forward
in a meaningful way
and at that time if you recall we had a
situation where tens of thousands of
people died every year in this country
because they didn't have quality
affordable health care so i said i'm
voting for this
i don't care what happens uh in the
election i'm going to vote for it but
i'll tell you i still
vividly remember pushing that green
button when we went up to vote
to vote for and i said this probably
means i'm not coming back to congress
but how often can you just push a button
and literally
save thousands of lives that's what we
need to make sure we do
and that is why we have to make sure
that we understand that that bill is on
the ballot this year once again
after all that fighting all that
struggling all the help that it's been
for folks all across the country it is
on the ballot
now because of trump's reckless lawsuit
for the supreme court which is going to
be taken up just a couple weeks after
this election
it could very well be thrown out we
think this new nominee has made it very
clear where her position is
it could be thrown out and what will
happen with when that occurs well we're
going to go back to the bad old days
where if you had a pre-existing
condition you're not protected
that means 1.7 million people in this
state
could lose the protections that they
have now even though they have
pre-existing condition and to think
we're in a pandemic where those numbers
of pre-existing conditions will go up we
could go back to the battle days when
being a woman
was a pre-existing condition we're going
to go back to the battle days when
seniors have to pay higher prescription
drug prices
on medicare we'll go back to the battle
days when folks didn't have access to
health care but because of the medicaid
expansion including the support from
governor whitmer to make sure that that
happened
800 000 people in our state now have
health care coverage
all of that could go away and they'll be
back to annual
caps being eliminated and and uh and the
lifetime caps eliminated so that folks
would may find themselves being forced
into bankruptcy if they have
a very difficult situation so donald
trump is
not alone in trying to dismantle the
affordable care act
my opponent in this senate race is also
opposed
in fact he supports donald trump 2
000 that's a pretty big percent 2000
and like donald trump he has no plan the
affordable care act is dismantled there
is no plan
whatsoever we've seen the republicans
have never come up with a plan they've
had time to do that they never do
and if you ask them or if you ask my
opponent what's the plan they'll give
you a blank stare
and then they'll have shallow talking
points and never address
the issues ladies and gentlemen these
are serious times we're in we're in the
middle of a pandemic we have folks that
are losing health care who are afraid
we need serious leadership
we need steady leadership ladies and
gentlemen we
need joe biden as the next president of
the united states
and joe biden also needs friends he
needs to have
a majority in the united states senate
so that we can move this agenda forward
he cannot do it along
and i'll just say in closing you know
this issue is not academic this is not
just
talk this is real it's very real there
are real stories there are people behind
all of these stories i
i still have visions of people as they
see the affordable care act perhaps
going away coming to my office in tears
not knowing what the future will mean
for them and for their families
people's lives literally hang in the
balance
and that's why i'm so proud to have the
opportunity to introduce
alexia mansour who will share her story
her story of what affordable health care
means to her
and means to her family so please
welcome alexia
[Music]
wow what an incredible honor
to be here today vice president biden
governor whitmer senator peters senator
sam now
i am truly humbled and grateful
to be here with all of you my name is
alexia mansour
i'm a stay-at-home mom of three amazing
children
sedela cidella h-10 azora age 8
and atticus h4 my husband michael
operates our small family business
spartan spirits
which has been a staple in the east
lansing community
founded by my father-in-law john nearly
30 years ago
our small business only employs two
people right now
and even when we're fully staffed our
staff members don't qualify our business
to negotiate with health care companies
to offer employee-sponsored health
insurance
because of that before the affordable
care act
my family didn't have health care
coverage until 2014.
we simply couldn't afford it
to say that to put a lot of stress on
our family is an understatement
my husband like so many americans has
mental health issues
that we're always made worse we couldn't
see a doctor
or take his medication regularly i lived
in constant
fear that if we lost him my kids would
lose their dad
i would lose my husband and we would
lose our business
when i was pregnant in 2010 and 2012
i remember trying to get coverage i'm
being told there's no way to get
coverage
at rates i could have ever afford
it really wasn't until the aca that we
could take a deep
breath you best believe as soon as that
marketplace opened up we were one of the
first families that signed up
for coverage a tremendous weight had
finally
been lifted from our shoulders we felt
protected
and safe and now my husband
actually is being taken care of
we can get the exams and testing we need
to have done
we haven't had to switch providers and
the pricing of our medication
are consistent and at prices we can
afford
i gotta tell you this has been a really
tough year
i know you can all feel me on that
our business has been hit hard by
covid19
we chose to close the store for three
weeks in an effort to protect those
around us
and to stop the spread of cobit 19.
since reopening business has been
unpredictable
at best and now with the delayed
football season
it's even worse we've had employees quit
because they're scared of contracting
the virus at work
my husband works seven days a week just
to keep our business doors open
but knowing that my kids and my family
have health care
no matter what gives us the peace of
mind that we can
get through this challenge
when i think about what the trump
administration is trying to do right now
i'm infuriated
they are playing games with my family's
lives
this president and this senate has had
four
years to come up with a plan they've had
four
years to prove they won't kick people
off their coverage
they've had four years to show us
they'll protect people with pre-existing
conditions like my husband
and they've done nothing but try to gut
the aca
at every single turn
that's why we need to elect joe biden
and gary peters
in november joe biden is someone we can
trust
he's someone with integrity who does
what he says he's going to do
he believes in science and i believe
in him
he believes in our country and wants to
do what's best
for all of us he will truly be a
president for
all of the american people regardless of
whether you voted for him
or not our current president doesn't
care much about me or my family
and he doesn't care much about our small
business either if he did he would have
taken this seriously
from the beginning he would have had a
plan
he would have tried to help more
and he wouldn't threaten to gut 20
million
people's health insurance during a
pandemic
we need to elect joe biden and kamala
harris
and we need to re-elect gary peters to
the senate
i truly believe they care about us
they'll fight for us and for our health
care
and with that i'd like to introduce i'm
so proud to say
our great governor gretchen whitmer
and our next president of the united
states
joe biden
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you i am so pleased to be
here with all of you and i'm so pleased
that joel biden is back
in michigan
now we all know this this is the most
important election in our lifetimes
and that's true for many reasons but one
of the most important compelling reasons
is the fact
that health care of millions of people
is on this ballot and this is a personal
issue
it's personal for so many families it's
personal for me
18 years ago i became a member
of the sandwich generation and that
simply means
i was sandwiched between two members of
my own family
for whom i was the primary caregiver my
mother at the end of her life
and my daughter at the beginning of hers
while my mom battled brain cancer
i was on the phone fighting her
insurance company
who was wrongfully denying covering her
chemotherapy
there are so many americans that have a
similar story
that have gone through this or are going
through it right now
the brain cancer that killed my mom was
the same kind that took vp biden's
son beau that period of my life was
devastating it was hard and it changed
me
and that's precisely why i've worked
across the
aisle to deliver health care for
michiganders
to ensure that we expanded medicaid
and now 800 000 people in this state
have health care because i was able to
work across the aisle
but it took working across the aisle to
get it done
we had a republican governor and i was
the senate democratic leader
and we left our partisan corners and
found common ground
because it was about the health of the
people of this state
i know that joe biden has done
and will continue to do the same as our
next president
i know that joe biden shows up and has
our back when we need him he worked with
president
obama he worked to expand health care to
millions of americans
he was here during the auto industry
rescue
michigan supports joel biden because joe
biden supports michigan now the joe
biden we all know and love is the joe
biden who rolls up his sleeves
and works to get things done and works
with anyone
he needs to in order to deliver he's
made lifelong friends on both sides of
the aisle
because he's a good decent human being
who cares about americans
all americans he's a fighter
who will protect and expand health care
good paying jobs jobs that people can
support a family on
and he will ensure that every american
no matter who they are
or where they come from has a fair shot
joe biden knows how to build bridges
he'll bring us together and make health
care more available
for more americans we know that
president trump
isn't focused on finding common ground
he's
been running a scorched earth agenda for
years
and not only does he want to take away
health care
but he's in court right now trying to
dismantle the aca
that has been a lifeline for so many
americans
instead of bringing the heat down he
ratchets it up with incendiary rhetoric
instead of building bridges he focuses
on building walls
he always has been and in this
upcoming election our choice
couldn't be more clear while joe biden
works to expand health care
in the midst of a global pandemic that's
killed more than two hundred
eighteen thousand americans nearly seven
thousand of whom are michiganders
the trump administration keeps working
to fight
to take that health care away instead of
keeping people safe
and delivering on federal relief
they deny science they contradict their
own
guidelines they mock people who wear
masks
they've even endangered their own
supporters
not only is the trump virus response
threatening our lives and our economy
but the trump administration continues
on their quest
that would deny coverage to people with
pre-existing conditions
over four million of whom are
michiganders
and now covet 19 that has ravaged our
country
is a pre-existing condition too nearly 8
million americans have been diagnosed
with covid19
and if the affordable care act is struck
down
those who have been diagnosed
are at they are at risk of losing their
coverage too
so the difference could be more clear
and that's why i'm optimistic
because with our historic leadership in
the world right now
our phenomenal capacity for cutting-edge
research
science industry innovation and
manufacturing
america could have and should have
led with an informed and unified coveted
response
that would have saved lives mitigated
the economic fallout
and made us a global leader the envy of
the world
but the sad truth is the trump
administration never had a plan to
protect americans
they squandered our might and our
capacity
by making this public crisis this public
health crisis
a political football it did not
have to be this way tens of thousands of
american deaths
could have been avoided had the
president treated covid19
like the crisis he knew it to be
from the beginning more than 60 million
people
filed for unemployment in the united
states 218
000 deaths lines of people at food
pantries
americans banned from traveling to other
countries
and the covid numbers keep
going up it is still getting
worse so to the americans
everywhere have been devastated by this
pandemic
there is good news there's a
incredibly decent man who is running for
president of the united states
who is fighting for you and your family
to the moms who are at home working
trying to get their kids logged onto
zoom
getting the laundry done taking care of
the family
joel biden works for you
to the small business owners who've
spent a lifetime building something
great
and are hanging on by their fingernails
joel biden
works for you to the grandparents who
haven't been able to see
much less hug their grandkids joe biden
works for you into the hundreds of
thousands of americans who've lost a
loved one
joe biden's working for you too
ask yourself this which
candidate can get covid19 crisis under
control
which man is going to get us back to
work
who could bring us together as a nation
in most years in presidential elections
there are two
decent choices this year
there is one joe biden
we must all vote like our lives
and our livelihoods and the soul of our
nation
depends on it because they do
and with that i want to introduce you to
my friend and our next
president joe biden
foreign
hello michigan
[Music]
hi how are you what's your name
sam good to see you man thanks for being
here
appreciate it
alexia thank you for uh
for uh taking the time telling your
story
it's uh it's important unfortunately
there are an awful lot of stories like
yours
all over america that travel the country
too many
don't have to be and uh folks it's great
to be back it's great to be here
there's not a better governor
in the united states of america than
gretchen
that's a fact
[Applause]
i've met virtually all in gary
we badly need you back in the united
states senate pal
we badly need you back united states
and my sister debbie stamina
god love you debbie we work so closely
together
for so long and as vice president as
well
folks look we need to send gary back to
another
term standing up for michigan michigan
families small businesses he was uh
he was our main congressional partner
back in 2010 when we passed the critical
legislation
supporting small businesses i remember
i remember the president giving me the
responsibility to go out and
and round up support the person i my
go-to guy
to get it done i mean sincerely was
was gary he was the go-to guy and he
always shows up and he always shows up
for michigan
like all of you jill and i are so
grateful that the governor
and her family are safe and it's a
it's an unusual year governor you've
been through a lot but my lord you are a
leader you stand up straight and tall
and you don't bend governor is not easy
to lead in moments of crisis
but that's a determination of whether
you have the real leader
when you stepped up to the crisis and
you've stepped up
you've done it and you keep doing it
as i said a moment ago you're pretty
much doing it better than anybody else
in the whole united states of america
you've shown this whole nation just how
tough and thoughtful you are tough
just like michigan i've got to believe
this state has to be so
proud of you i know personally i am as
i've gotten to know you
i'm proud to call your friend gov we're
grateful to the fbi and law enforcement
to discover these domestic terrorists
and stop them and make no mistake
that's who they are domestic terrorists
flat terrorists
[Applause]
planning to blow up a bridge on american
soil to threaten the lives of police
officers
to kidnap an elected leader and now
we're finding out the same thing was
happening
in virginia you know it's the sort of
behavior
you might expect from isis and it
shouldn't shock the conscience of
every american every american and the
failure to condemn
these folks is stunning
from the outset you might remember
it matters you've heard me say it before
words
matter and the words of a president
particularly matter
when the president tweeted liberate
michigan liberate michigan
that's the call that was heard
that was the dog whistle just like when
he said
there were quote very fine people
on both sides in charlottesville fathers
they came out of the
fields carrying torches their veins just
balding
bulging shouting anti-semitic pile
carrying nazi flags accompanied by the
ku klux klan
when a young woman was killed protesting
president was asked what do you think he
said something
no president has ever ever ever ever
heard
they were very fine people
on both sides
those words were heard just like when he
stood on the debate stage with me and
refused to denounce
white supremacist who told that white
ring extremist group to quote stand back
and stand by
stand back and stand by
an american president
not only shocked us
but it stunned the world
those words we heard you know the reason
i decided to run for president
and i know that debbie knows this
i hadn't planned on running ever again
after my son died
when i saw those folks coming out of
those woods
i thought how in god's name
how in god's name can remain silent
i said at the time it was somewhat not
criticized but
people didn't think it was well i don't
know what it was
and i said i think we're in a battle for
the soul of america
i think we are what i saw at
charlottesville and the president's
response
to it is why i went to
gettysburg battlefield of pennsylvania
last week
because i thought there was a need to
stand up to hate in america
and urge us as lincoln did to come
together as a nation
what i've learned hate
never goes away it only hides
it never goes away and if you give it
oxygen
it comes out from under the rocks it
grows
we need to be clear from the present
on down in this country there is no
place
for hate in america period none
will not be tolerated
but president trump rebels in division
and chaos
to do anything to distract us from
focusing on his
failures to deal with this virus
to protect the nation
he's still living in a dream world he
keeps stealing
he keeps telling us that this virus is
going to disappear like america
he said i think last night in his town
hall i didn't have the pleasure of
hearing it
i was doing one myself
he said we have turned the corner
my grandfather finnegan might say we're
here he said
he's gone around the bend
turn the corner my lord
it's not disappearing in fact it's on
the rise again
it's getting worse as predicted
we all know the terrible price this
nation has paid
lives lost employment away unemployment
way up across michigan in the country
folks are worried about making their
next rent payment or mortgage payment
but their health care will be ripped
away in the middle of a pandemic
that you worked so damn hard gary to
keep
worried about and we talked about this
alexis
kids in school are they able to get back
to school
more than 215 000 americans i think it's
217
as of this morning americans have died
from covert 19.
and experts have said and have been
saying for the last month and a half
that nearly another 200 000 lives
are like to be lost likely to be lost in
the coming months
between now and the first of the year
if if we continue to refuse
to follow science because he refused to
embrace him
wearing a mask how many times
intelligence he make fun of biden
wearing a mask
because he refuses
to practice social distancing he puts
his supporters in such
jeopardy it's estimated
by his own folks if we just
wore masks nationally
almost 100 000 lives would be saved
in the next few months his own director
of cdc
said we're waiting for a vaccine if we
had a vaccine
this will prevent more deaths
between now and the end of january
than a vaccine would you know what's
really sad about all this
i've been talking about this but every
time i repeat it i get more
well i'm not very happy
the president knew and lied about
knowing
he knew in january
the intelligence community and their
what they call the pdb the presidential
daily briefings
which i've sat in on hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
them
as vice president
it cut out that they laid out in detail
to him how devastating
this could be how
much life could be lost
so on he said he was unaware
didn't read those reports well that
surprised no one that didn't read the
reports but
he didn't read the reports everybody
said well maybe he didn't
but then as was acknowledged because of
his ego he wanted to impress
a famous journalist he thought he could
change his mind about his view of him
he did a long interview with bob
woodward
bob woodward
renowned journalist taped the interview
with him extensive interviews hours
and he taped an interview that where
trump said
he knew this disease was deadly
significantly worse than the flu
that's not what he told you
that's not what he told the public
the reason he lied again to the american
people
well he said he didn't want to
panic the american people
americans don't panic donald trump
panicked that's who panicked
as a consequence it was overwhelming
lying negligence is an irresponsible
action
how many empty chairs around the kitchen
table this morning at the dining room
table last night
how many
how many women are men leaned over and
they got in bed last night they reached
over to touch their husband and wife
and they weren't there
you all know what loss is
it's profound especially
when it was avoidable much of it
but mishandling the pandemic isn't
enough for trump
on top of that he's still trying to take
away your health care
trump's still determined in the midst of
this pandemic
by the way if projections pray god
they're not right father if they're
right though
in the next several months would be over
200 000
additional deaths that'll be in one year
400 000 people one of americans will die
that's more than lost in all of world
war ii hear me
world war ii was four years
more american souls would have been lost
in a world war ii
what's he doing he's still determined
to destroy the affordable care act
this isn't hyperbole just like your
opponent
calls it a disaster talk about a
disaster there's a disaster
the guy is 2 000 or 200
whatever it is with trump hope everybody
remembers
look as i said this isn't hyperbole it's
real as real as it gets
on november 10th the united states
supreme court will hear the trump
administration
make the case that the affordable care
act should be struck down
in its entirety
i know everybody thinks they know but i
just want to remind you
10 million of you have already lost your
health insurance because your employers
health insurance they've gone out of
business
10 million americans already without
health insurance
if trump gets his way 20 million more
americans will lose their health care
it's a god awful in the midst of this
god-awful economic crisis
100 million americans will lose their
protections for pre-existing conditions
including more than four million people
right here in michigan
lifetime limits and benefits
on benefits will be back
insurance and by the way you know
a lot of you've been through what i've
been through and worse
but i can distinct and remember
sitting on a bed with my bow my son
who came back from the attorney general
came back from a year
serving in iraq which this president
talks about losers who serve
losers
with the same
significant disease that your mom had
stage four glioblastoma
when it was diagnosed when he got home
we asked the docs it was only a matter
of months not if
just months we never gave up hope
i remember watching him on that bed
he made it almost 16 months
toward the end this is not about me it's
about all of you
i consciously thought to myself
what would it feel like if they were
able to walk in and say
mr biden you've outrun your insurance
coverage
suffered the last two or three months
in pain on your own lots of luck
because that's what has happened before
insurers if they win
and that's what this court packing going
on now is about
insurers will no longer allow you to
keep your kids on your policy until age
26 in the middle of this economic crisis
women once again will be charged more
for their health care just because
they're a woman
older folks will be able to be charged
more
and as the governor said long-term
complications from covet
will become pre-existing conditions
joining asthma diabetes
even pregnancies a pre-existing
condition before
it could allow insurers to jack up your
premiums or deny coverage altogether
getting rid of obamacare
is why they're racing to get this
nominee through the supreme court
make no mistake about it trump's made it
clear from the beginning as your
opponent has
he wants to get rid of obamacare in its
entirety
and with this nominee he's made that
incredibly clear
as well michigan deserves so much better
deserves leaders like gary and debbie
stabenow
public servants who lead with decency
and honor
always look out for your needs
think about how to ease the burden on
your family
that's the sort of leader you got in
gretchen and governor whitmer as well
when she was in the state senate she led
the charge to secure obamacare
medicaid expansion for more than 800 000
michiganders think about this now
some of those states republican
governors did not expand
even though the federal government's
paying for the front end
there's millions of people have no
coverage
after we passed obamacare with the help
of debbie and gary
with debbie stabenow and gary peters
we're able to reduce the uninsured rate
by
55 here in michigan
and if i have the honor of becoming your
president will build on the affordable
care act no matter what they do
you can choose to keep a private plan if
you still have one
because some of the private plans
negotiated the ufw and others are good
plans
but we'll also offer you a medicare-like
public health insurance option
it'll force private insurers to keep
premiums low and offer better coverage
because it's for the first time
you'll have to compete for your business
against a public insurer that doesn't
have to profit motivated by it
if you choose this public option or a
private plan we'll increase subsidies
for your premiums
so that they're lower you can afford our
plans with lower deductibles lower
out-of-pocket spending
an independent analysis found that my
plan will slash the cost of prescription
jokes
by 60 not a liberal think tank
serious folks looking at this here's the
bottom line
my plan lowers health care costs and
gets universal coverage quickly
at a time when michigan families
desperately are going to need that
relief and they need it now
families are reeling right now
they need a lifeline now
i promise you when i'm president i'll
take care of your health coverage the
same way i would my own family
i grew up like a lot of people in this
state
scranton pennsylvania and wilmington
delaware a three-bedroom foot level home
with
four kids and grandfathers
i can remember how my dad when we moved
from scranton with no work
we moved down to delaware we stayed with
my grandpa for a year
came home every weekend finally got a
job we got an apartment
we lived in and ended up being section 8
housing years later but it was
decent we were happy i took my dad about
three years to get a job good enough he
could actually
buy a home he bought that small home at
the time a suburban sprawl was going on
there were 70 homes like it three and
four bedrooms homes
but the walls were thin i look back and
wonder how my mom and dad did it come to
think of it
i remember one night my dad's being
really readily you could hear him
restlessly rolling that our bedroom was
next to it
i asked my mom the next point what's
wrong with dad
he said honey it's complicated
i said what's the matter mom i was like
14 years old
so well this company just lost his
health insurance
going to be okay
all the people rolling around in bed
tonight
tomorrow night last night
trump doesn't see things this way
because he only sees things sees the
world
from a park avenue perspective i'm not
being a wise guy i'm being literal
he can only see from his penthouse wall
street
i see the world where i grew up like
many of you i grew up in scranton as i
said
my mom taught me my mom had a backbone
like a ramrod
my mom told me she said joey look at me
look at me
because i used to study nobody's better
than you joey
but everybody's your equal that's how i
was raised
i think you and i we measure people
whether you're a democrat or republican
we measure people
on the strength of their character
honesty decency
recognizing that some things are bigger
than just your self-interest
that's what america is about that's who
we are
it's about family respect decency honor
opportunity
our families and yours weren't asking
for anything just a shot
just an even shot give it a shot the
american people have never ever ever
ever ever let their country down
that's what michigan needs now a shot to
come back strong
not what you needed 10 years ago in your
automobile industry
the heart and soul of michigan was on
the brink
my state used to be in auto state small
population we had the highest percentage
of auto workers of any state in the
nation
because we had less than a million
people
the largest general motors and chrysler
plants
outside of michigan
but you all remember like i do you
remember what it was like yesterday
when barack and i decided we had to bet
on michigan
remember all the blow back even from
democrats
we can't compete we bet on
auto workers we bet on the uaw and they
came through and it paid off
for real the industry wasn't in trouble
because your auto worker was in trouble
because of management decisions
over the objective of many we stepped in
and rescued the automobile institute
general motors and chrysler saving over
one million
jobs by that one deal
don't ever underestimate the american
worker
by contrast on donald trump's watch
we were in a nationwide manufacturing
recession before
kovitz struck
we're now down nearly 650 000
manufacturing jobs across the country
now now
it's rising in fact donald trump
will be the first president in modern
american history
to leave office god willing to leave
office
with fewer jobs than he had when he
started
in office last one was herbert hoover
for real folks we can bring this economy
back
i'm positive of it i'm optimistic about
it
we know how to go about doing an
independent analysis on wall street
moody's a well-respected
wall street firm has done an in-depth
analysis of every aspect of my
plan as well as his
you know what the conclusion was this is
moody's now
that my plan will create 18.6 million
jobs 7 million more than his would
and one trillion dollars more in
economic growth
than the president's plan by investing
in people
and by the way you see these ads here in
michigan
wyden's going to raise your taxes once
again
flat unadulterated lie
no one who makes less than 400
000 a year will pay a penny more if you
make more than that you're going to
start paying at the rate you paid under
the administration of george w
bush at 39.6 percent
but i'm going to ask big corporations
and they're very wealthy to
pay their fair share for a change
trump's more than two trillion dollar
tax cut
i'm going to roll back 1.5 trillion of
that
in the giveaways of the biggest company
in the tops one percent
and the money we raise will invest in
working people
growing the middle class this time make
sure we bring
everybody along black white hispanic
disabled everyone comes along
an outside economist said my plan will
create millions of good paying union
jobs in manufacturing
we're gonna invest in building more
resilient infrastructure
remember the president said i have an
infrastructure plan
in 2017 and then 2018 and 2019.
now 2020. he doesn't have any plan
i'm going to build a resilient
infrastructure creating good paying jobs
building roads and bridges
and ports 1 million new jobs and
affordable housing units should be one
million new
affordable housing units high-speed
broadband
for every household 100 billion dollars
to rebuild our crumbling schools
one of the reasons we can't send our
kids back to schools a lot of them
aren't even safe
now
we're going to retrofit as we start in
our administration when the president
allowed me to run the recovery act
we're going to retrofit 4 million
buildings
and weatherize 2 million homes that
alone
will save hundreds of thousands and
millions of barrels of oil
and it's all going to be done by
certified
union labor
we're gonna end trump's incentive he
actually priced a lot
he's talking he talks about his trade
deals
as gary and debbie know his trade deals
he incentivized people to send jobs
abroad
abroad more taking their jobs overseas
one thing more the united states
government owns and maintains
enormous fleet of vehicles and i promise
you
the president controls that i'm going to
convert those government fleets into
clean vehicles made
and sourced right here in the united
states of america i'm going to expand
the capacity
so the united states not china leads the
world in clean
vehicle production we're going to make
it easier for america's cooper to switch
from fuel-efficient via inefficient
vehicles
we're going to build a network of 500
000 charging stations all across the
country
offer consumer rebates to swap older
inefficient
fuel and efficient vehicles for new
clean american-made models and together
this will mean according to the
estimates more than a
million good new jobs in the american
automobiles because we will
own the electric vehicle market in the
world
folks i guarantee we can do this
but we have to come together
i remember you and i talking gov
when i was running for the nomination in
my saying we had to unite the country
you're the only one that thought i was
right i think he said that used to be
the old days
yeah joe you got a lot done you used to
walk across
i'll get a lot done but everything's
changed
well folks if we can't unite the country
we're in trouble america
and our system runs on consensus
compromise is not a dirty word
i'm running as a proud democrat but i'm
going to govern as an american president
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me
as those who do i do not see america in
terms of red and blue
bringing the country together that's the
job of a president
it's a duty to care to care for
everybody
we can be so much better than what we
see
we can be what we are at our best when
we're the united
states of america but folks
you have to vote and people are turning
out here in this state in overwhelming
numbers around the country
if you have any doubt go visit
iwillvote.com
m i
early voting is happening now
and every city and township clerk's
office in the state
you can register and vote in one quick
stop
you have your ballot already mail it or
drop it in a
dropbox today don't wait
vote don't just vote for me and senator
harris and gary as well
vote all the way down the line we're
going to need gary back in the united
states senate
looking out for michigan families
because we're going to win back the
united states senate when we do we're
going to change things
folks it's time
i really mean this to restore the soul
of america
to rebuild the backbone of this country
the middle class
this time as i'd bring everybody along
debbie may remember my colleagues in the
caucus used to wonder
kid me because i'd quote president
kennedy
when he was about going to the moon in a
famous speech everybody remembers
different parts of it
the one iron line i remember more than
anything else
he answered the question that wasn't was
implicitly being asked
why are you doing this and he said
because we refuse to postpone
i refuse to postpone the work america
must do
now to bring this country back there's
nothing beyond our capacity
there's no limit to american future the
only thing that can tear america apart
is america itself no other country can
do that
everybody knows who donald trump is we
have to let them know who we are what we
stand for
we choose hope over fear unity over
division
science over fiction and yes truth over
lies
so folks
thank you and may god bless you and make
god protect our troops
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
got to make the world go round
slip into the mud
got to make the world go round
is
youngest child is
good
all right
hook the camera
you